What's your background? Hello. Can you
hear me, sir? Yes. Okay. Um, my
background is Muslim. Um, I I grew up I
grew up in a Muslim family. Okay.
Although my father's a very hardline
atheist. He wouldn't let me talk about
religion at all anywhere. So, um, I have
some doubts about, you know, um, Islam.
That's why I'm usually on your shows.
Sorry. It's the first time I'm seeing
the name Hoola. No, no, it's actually I
just put it put it wrong. I'm Turkish.
Um this ul so yeah I haven't seen you
but okay what's going on? So um the
issue is um the more I keep reading into
the scriptures of you know the scripture
I call it the scripture bible and the
more I keep the more I read about it you
know the more I read in different
chapters the old testament the new
testament yes um there's a consistent
message that's coming from the prophets
and all the way to Jesus all all them
pointing to Jesus so and Jesus is coming
obviously telling knew that I'm here to
fulfill and then he does fulfill and
people see him resurrected.
Um, and they build a church on it which
is a miracle. Exactly. Like like how can
you build a church and die a martyr if
you don't believe what you're telling is
true. And
it's just very um
astonishing coming from a Muslim
background because when you grow up in a
Muslim family, people keep telling you,
"Oh, this didn't happen. He didn't die
on the cross. He didn't resurrect. He's
alive or he's in the heaven sitting with
God doing whatever." I don't know. Um I
just have one thing I have to understand
before I can um accept what's in the
Bible. Sure. Go ahead. Uh, it's a bit
difficult for me. Sorry, I keep
mumbling. Don't worry about it. Uh, uh,
my policy, if someone sincerely asks,
take your time. It's the trolls that
come and mock that I cuss out. But go
ahead. No, why I mean, why would someone
come to your show and be a troll? I
don't know. I don't know. Believe me,
man. You should see what they say. But
that's okay. I'm glad you I I be I want
to be as genuine as I can and ask you.
Um, I I I mean, no disrespect. I intend
no disrespect. Why why does Paul or
maybe I don't understand this, but why
does Paul not not speak any clearer and
say, "Well, Jesus actually God um in the
flesh." I keep I keep reading into maybe
it's the first century monotheistic Jews
and they would just stone him for it.
Maybe that's why he's just he keeps uh
talking in different um like disguised
manner.
To make to answer your question simpler,
how would you want Paul to articulate
that he's God? Because you're saying he
could make it in clear. Paul is clear.
And it's not way just before you go in.
We don't just base the claims of
divinity Christ on what Paul said. It's
on what Mark, Matthew, Luke, John, Acts,
as well as Jesus himself. But what would
in your mind constitute clearer? Like
for example, uh, second Peter 1, he
literally calls him our God and Savior.
But that's Peter. So then why don't you
take Peter's testimony? I take it. I
take it. And that's why I'm a bit
baffled by because I now have to accept
it if I'm honest.
Okay. So what do you do with Titus 2:13?
Because before Peter says it, Paul said
it. Looking for the blessed hope and the
appearing of the glory of our great God
and Savior Jesus Christ.
Oh Uh, okay. So yeah,
why you buddy? Sorry. While you were
reciting the Quran, you just said, "Oh
shit."
Oh, so no, no, no. Um, so I Okay, that
means I'm not very learned about the New
Testament yet. Okay. See, I have never
seen that before. Our great God and
Savior Christ. Okay. But does that say
the same thing in the Greek scriptures
on or the King James version of it? Does
it say the same thing? Second Peter 1:1,
brother. It's called the grand
construction. Here, let me walk you
through this. In fact, two examples of a
grand full sharp construction. I mean, I
don't want to get technical to on you,
but yes. So, when you say Paul didn't,
how much clearer could Paul be if he
says that Christ one who created
everything and he sustains everything?
Hold on. Titus 2:13.
Here it is. You can even read the
transliteration.
Doxis
megalu
the great God.
All right. Oh god. Okay. The glory of
the great God and savior of us. Okay.
Fair enough. Okay. Second Peter 1:1
which you said it was about Christ. Now
one thing I need you to see though. So
you can see see this this two right
here. Yeah. Okay. That's the definite
article. That's the right. Yes, that's
true. So you see the definite article
appears before meu
the great god. Correct. Yes. True. Now
you see there is no definite article
before this one, right? No. The great
god and savior. Yes. If it was the great
god and the savior that would be two
different people. Not always. It can
mean but it's not necessary. The context
will determine it. We because the King
James because the King James I'm sorry
to interrupt you. I'm sorry again. The
King James Bible uh says of our God and
our savior Jesus Christ like like it
like kind of separates the two in second
Peter one. Hold on. Let me go to the
there one second.
Okay.
But even then that's not two. That's I'm
saying no does not mean it's two can and
can't.
Uhhuh.
By the right. Oh, I'm sorry. I'm in the
wrong translation.
What the What's up with the background
noise? What are you in a Sorry, I'm at
work. That's why I just kept I just kept
the u I just put um the phone work or
you're in a you're in opera like you're
in a theater. No, no, no, no. As the
deer panteth for the waters. All right.
the righteousness of God and our savior
Jesus Christ. Okay. So even then
in light of Elizabeth and English there
are examples in which you find similar
wording and it's referring to one
person. So this in itself does not mean
it's two two persons but
and here
the of the great God and our savior
Jesus Christ identical again. Yeah. But
my point is if you look at the Greek
because you brought up the King James.
Do you see the article is only here,
right? Yes. So it's the of the great god
and savior. There is no the here, right?
Yes. Sure. So this is a particular Greek
construction. Okay. Known as ramble
sharp. I'm not going to get technical.
This is a rule of Greek grammar and
rules are discovered. You don't invent
rules. You study language and see
what rules govern
certain phrases, conjunctions, and so on
and so forth. Anyway, in examining this
particular Greek construction, every
time in the New Testament, when you find
two nouns, this is a noun, God. This is
a noun, savior. Mhm. You find two nouns
connected by this word and, you see it?
Yeah. So, God, Savior, and the nouns are
singular. See, they're not plural.
They're not proper names. In other
words, doesn't say and Sam. Okay. So,
when you have two nouns, here's a noun.
Here's a noun. They're singular. It's
not saviors, God's. It's God's savior.
Yeah. Connected by an and you have the
definite article appearing before the
first noun, but not before the second.
That construction always refers to one
and the same entity. It's never
okay. That's Yeah. Yeah, that's fair
enough. I I understand it. Yeah. So, if
I say the great God and Savior of us
right there, I'm referring to one, not
two, right? But then fine. Yeah. Then he
fills it out. But who is this great God
and Savior?
Yesu Jesus Christ, right? Yeah. Yeah.
But now let's look at second Peter 1:1.
Second Peter 1:1.
Here you go.
You think, guys, you think Michelle
Lonia could do this? So, he's got to go
flip burgers. Anyway,
once let me show you right here. Boom.
I'm going to give give you the Greek
again. Now, tell me if it's identical.
The only things missing is megalith.
Great. Okay. So, there's that word too,
right? Yes.
So yeah, that's an article.
Exactly as you showed me. Titus in the
Titus one. Exactly. Yep. The only thing
is the Hmon here it was placed after
Sautieros. Here it's after God. But that
just that's irrelevant. That's still
Yeah. We do the same thing in English
though as well. I mean I like it's like
it's like me telling you I tell him to
do something or I told something to him
like that kind of um Yeah. Yeah. Mhm.
Mhm. Okay. I'm I'm convinced now. Okay.
I'm convinced that Paul actually claimed
it very boldly. Okay. Okay. Yeah. And he
he doesn't need to claim it in just one
way. The name of the true God in the
Bible is Yahweh. Right. Yeah.
When they rendered the Hebrew into
Greek, what is the Greek word they use
for Yahweh?
Um,
they used for I don't understand. Can
you tell me again? Okay. When they
translated the Old Testament into Greek
because it's written in Hebrew. Yes.
When the divine name Yahweh appeared,
Kevin Young, thank you, Joe. Uh, Yahweh
appeared. Yeah.
When they translate it into Greek, what
word did they use for Yahweh? Uh, I'm
guess I don't know. I'm not very
learned. I'm sorry. Is it Theo? Well,
that's all right. No, what did they use?
Is it Theo? No, Theo is the name of my
neighbor. No, Theos is God. No, sorry.
Yeah, Theos. Yeah, Theos. But no, theos
means God. That would be the rendering
of Elohim. Let's say if the Hebrew said
Elohim. Yeah. or or
then that would be rendered as theos
God. The word they use for Yahweh is the
Greek word girus. Okay. Lord, right?
Yeah. Okay. Now, why is that important?
Because watch here. Here it is.
Deuteronomy 6:4. Here Israel, Yahweh is
our God. Yahweh is one. Now, when Mark
quotes Jesus and writes it in Greek, now
watch here. Yahweh is our God. Yahweh is
one. Notice the words he's going to use.
Jesus answered the foremost says here
Ora, the Lord our God is one Lord. So
notice he's using the word Lord what?
To say about to say about God Yahweh. So
what this word Lord is being used as a
substitute for what name here? Yahweh.
Okay, keep that in mind. The Greek is
Gerus. Gerius. Let me show because
you're going to see how they identify
Jesus as Yahweh. If you know this. Yeah.
I Yeah. Yeah. I know that. Call him
curios because they the eastern Orthodox
they call him curios in their chants and
songs. The problem is kerio or when they
say kirun
the word kirus
can also simply mean master or owner.
Yeah.
So the argument isn't
that the word kirus always means Yahweh.
Don't confuse the argument. I need you
to listen attentively. Okay. Yeah.
The argument is when they translate the
Hebrew
to Greek
they would use the word
Lord Yahweh. But you would have to
determine that from the context. meaning
it's the context that will tell you, oh,
here the word Gideius Lord is being used
for Yahweh. Mhm. And you'll know that if
they're citing an Old Testament passage
that has the name Yahweh, right? Yeah.
True. So, how do I know in Mark 12 the
Greek year where it says
uh kuvi is now here girius. How do I
know that here the word girus
is being used for Yahweh? Yeah.
I mean because of the things you just
explained to me because the Lord is used
because when Jesus was quoting
Deuteronomy 6:4
Yeah. No, that's No, you got the
principle. So it's I know here is
referring to Yahweh or as someone
pronounc it because he's quoting a text
where the name Yahweh appears but it's
being substituted by this word, right?
Yeah. All right. Now, now why is this
important? I want you to watch this.
That's why I got to go watch the series
I did on this. But here I'm going to
just give you an example. So here I keep
I keep watching your videos. Yeah. I'm
I'm trying to learn stuff. Um yeah. So
here I want you to see something. Let me
do it the opposite way. All right. Let
me close here. I want you to catch how
do you how do you remember even all
this? Like how do you remember those the
blessed me with recall? So this is
something I've been blessed with for the
glory of Jesus Christ since I was young.
I've been able to do this since I'm
talking about this not something now
even at 23 years ago. So I realized that
was just a favor from the Holy Spirit.
Now watch this. Joel 2:32. Mhm. And will
be that everyone who calls on the name
of Yahweh will be delivered. So whose
name do you call on? Yahweh. All right.
Now let me show you something
interesting. When this is quoted in
Greek here it is forever. I know this I
know this chapter. Uh okay. Right.
calls
for brotherham.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm just I'm just
astonished because now it makes sense.
Yeah. So, whoever calls on the name of
the Lord will be saved. So, here Paul
quotes it but in Greek he uses the word
kus which is Lord in English. So, what
is he quoting though? He's quoting Joel.
Um and yeah, he says whoever calls the
name of Yahweh will be delivered. So,
but here the word Yahweh is replaced by
what? Lord. So, but you know that here
the Lord that you call on is Yahweh,
right? Yes. But now watch who this Lord
is now. Catch it. Now the connection.
You ready? I'm scared. Tell me. Okay.
That if you confess with your mouth
Jesus as Lord. Mhm. And believe in your
heart that God raised him and from that
you'll be saved. So who is the one you
call on? Who is the Lord that you must
call? Yahweh. Yahweh. In the context,
who is it? Jesus. You got it. Does that
mean Jesus is also Yahweh of the Old
Testament? Exactly, buddy. That's the
point. Okay. Okay. So, if Jesus is
Yahweh, then what does that make him?
Makes him the true God, right? Yes.
Okay. Okay. Now, Okay. Um, thank you. I
mean, you've clarified so many things in
my head. Yeah.
Thanks. So, what's what's stopping you,
though? Uh, nothing actually. I just
need to learn more about it. Um, and
find a church. Um, yeah. Well, what area
you're in, but your only options is look
to the ancient churches, right? Yes. I I
I'm more drawn to the Catholic Church
because of the miracle that it was
assembled. Say it again. Speak louder.
You went down. Because of what? Uh
because of the c because of the miracle
that the church was built on. Yes. Uh,
so I think it's it looks like a I mean
true church. I mean I'm not very
learned. So I'll go read about the
history. Yes. Um and see what they what
they're saying about what what these men
saying say about you know miracle. What
miracle of what how can how can someone
build a church if they didn't believe he
was resurrected? Oh yeah. Yeah. member
though that that's the Coptic, Oriental,
Eastern Orthodox churches, Syrian
church, the eastern Catholics all
believe that. So when you say the
miracle, your reasons for becoming
Catholic or Eastern Orthodox, it's going
to have to be based on you resurrection.
They all believe in the resurrection.
Brother, brother, he killed me, brother.
Good. You cut me up and you still So
you're saying Easter Orthodox don't
believe in the resurrection? No, no, no.
didn't say that. No. Okay. So, that's
what I'm saying. This is the common
deposit of faith for all these churches.
Okay. All these churches believe this or
you're not a church. So, Eastern
Orthodox believes the resurrection.
Okay. Oriental Orthodox believes in
resurrection. Assyrian church believes.
My point is your reason for becoming
Catholic has to be based on because of
St. Peter. I mean, he was given the keys
of the church. I think in Matthew, how
old are you, young man? I am 25. I've
turned 25. Notice you're so excited. You
cut me out before I make the point. I'm
sorry. Yeah. Sorry. No, you're not.
Sorry, brother. It's okay, man. I I wish
I can be there to see you get baptized
because in my tradition, everyone who
gets baptized gets belted across the
jaw. Can you come to my church? Cuz I
want you to get baptized and I just want
to smack the taste out your mouth and
bless you, brother. Patience. Okay.
Listen. There is not a church that is
ancient that denies that St. Peter was
given the keys. See, you're not
listening. Sorry. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm scared to speak because I'm waiting
for you to cut me off. Okay. Repeat what
my answer was. How you going to know
what the true church is? Go ahead.
Repeat it because you were not
listening.
Sorry. So, you said what's You were not
listening. Oh, you you shut I thought
you listen. Do you want to listen or I I
will listen. I will shut my mouth.
Sorry.
For you to want to become Catholic has
to be based on your conviction that the
evidence shows you this is the fullness
of the truth. Don't give me well yeah
the miracle the resurrection they all
believe in it.
Don't give me well Peter was given the
keys. They all believe this. So you will
become Catholic because you're convinced
it has the fullness of truth. Now let me
explain what I mean by fullness. Eastern
Orthodox, Oriental Orthodox, Syrian
Church, Catholic. They all have the same
God, same scriptures, same trinity.
Okay? Yes. Yeah. We have wolves in our
midst and we have division in all of us.
But here's the thing. They're all
ancient. They all go back to the
apostles. Now, I've given this analogy
because I got it from Hank Kanograph.
You may not know who he is. Hank
Kanograph, Bible answer man. Bible
answer man who became Greek Orthodox
because he kept studying became Greek or
now he says imagine the Christian faith
is a dollar bill because you have
counterfeit right counterfeit money
right Jehovah's Witnesses Mormons they
have a counterfeit dollar
counterfeit
but Eastern Orthodox Syrian Church of
the East oriental Orthodox Catholics
they have the real dollar bill but how
many cents are there in a
um 100. You got it. So the argument is
one of them has 98 cents,
the other has 97 cents. Okay? Someone
has 95 cents, one has 99 cents. In other
words, they all have the same dollar,
but one of them has more of the dollar
than the other. That's the argument.
Okay,
you got it now. Yes. Yes. Yes. I I So
you want more of the dollar, right? Cuz
you're greedy. It looks like you're
cheap.
Yes. Yes, sir. True. So, you're you're
like very stingy. So, you want every
penny of the dollar. So, that's why
you're going to see which church has
more the fullness of the truth and has
preserved it and have has understood the
positive faith and correctly interpreted
it because I'm a stingy Turkish guy
who's so cheap that even when I drink
Turkish cafe, I reuse the cafe because I
don't want to buy new Turkish cafe.
Right. True. At least not. So that's
your journey, brother. But you're ready
now to submit yourself fully to the
triune God because the triune God lives.
Jesus is Lord. He's alive. This is not
the end of us. So begin your journey.
Okay? And I will continue to watch your
streams. But how do you begin your
journey? Go visit the Catholic Church.
But now be careful. You have liberal
priests who are corrupting the church
from within. and liberal Eastern
Orthodox. Go find you a solid
traditional Catholic church, solid
traditional Eastern Orthodox church,
solid traditional oriental Orthodox
church. Go find those that are
conservative and traditional and not
poisoned by liberalism.
Even in the Catholic tradition, you have
the Eastern right, you have the
Byzantine right, you have the Latin
mass. And I've been told by people who
go to the Latin mass, it is the most
beautiful experience. You'll be floored
and in awe of how holy and sacred it is.
Okay. Okay, brother. Okay. I'll keep
watching
and when you get more of that dollar,
then you can buy me some Turkish cafe.
We'll do, sir. I know. All right. Okay.
I'll see you later questions. God bless
you, brother. You too. Thank you. Bye
bye. So pray for